when you have a multi variable function
something that takes in multiple
different input values and let's say
it's just outputting a single number a
very common thing you want to do with an
animal like this is maximize it maximize
it and what this means is you're looking
for the input points the values of x and
y and all of its other inputs such that
the output f is as great as it possibly
can be now this actually comes up all
the time in practice because usually
when you're dealing with a multi
variable function it's not just for fun
and for dealing with abstract symbols
it's because it actually represents
something so maybe it represents like
profits of a company maybe this is a
function where you're considering all
the choices you can make like the wages
you give your employees or the prices of
your goods or the you know amount of
debt that you raise for capital all
sorts of choices that you might make and
you want to know what values should you
give to those choices such that you
maximize profits you maximize the thing
and if you have a function that models
these relationships there are techniques
which I'm about to teach you that you
can use to maximize this another very
common setting more and more important
these days is that of machine learning
and artificial intelligence
we're often what you do is you assign
something called a cost function to a
task so maybe you're trying to teach a
computer how to understand audio or how
to read handwritten text what you do is
you find a function that basically tells
it how wrong it is when it makes a guess
and if you do a good job designing that
function you just need to tell the
computer to minimize so that's kind of
the flip side right instead of finding
the maximum to minimize a certain
function and if it minimizes this cost
function that means that it's doing a
really good job at whatever task you've
assigned it so a lot of the art and
science of machine learning and
artificial intelligence comes down to
what one finding this cost function
actually actually describing difficult
tasks in terms of a function but then
applying the techniques that I'm about
to teach you to have the computer
minimize that and a lot of time and
research has gone into figuring out ways
to basically apply these techniques but
really quickly and efficiently so first
of all on a conceptual level let's just
think about what it means to be finding
the maximum of a multi variable function
so I have here the graph of a two
variable function that's something that
has a two variable input that we're
thinking of as the XY plane and then its
output is the height
of this graph and if you're looking to
maximize it basically what you're
finding is this peak kind of the tallest
mountain in the entire area and you're
looking for the input value the point on
the XY plane directly below that peak
because that tells you the values of the
inputs that you should put in to
maximize your function so how do you go
about finding that well this is perhaps
the core observation in more calculus
not just multivariable calculus this is
similar in the single variable world and
their similarities in other settings but
the core observation is that if you take
a tangent plane at that peak so let's
just draw in a tangent plane at that
peak it's going to be completely flat
but let's say you did this at a
different point right because if you
tried to find the tangent plane not at
that point but you kind of moved it
about a bit to somewhere that's not
quite a maximum if the tangent plane has
any kind of slope to it what that's
telling you is that if you take very
small directions kind of in the
direction of that upward slope you can
increase the value of your function so
if there's any slope to the tangent
plane you know that you can walk in some
direction to increase it but if there's
no slope to it if it's flat then that's
a sign that no matter which direction
you walk you're not going to be
significantly increasing the value of
your function so what does this mean in
terms of formulas well if you kind of
think back to how we compute tangent
planes and if you're not very
comfortable with that now would be a
good time to take another look at those
videos about tangent planes the slope of
the plane in each direction so you know
this would be the slope in the X
direction and then if you look at it
from another perspective this would be
the slope in the Y direction each one of
those has to be 0 and that in terms of
partial derivatives means the partial
derivative of your function at whatever
point you're dealing with right so I'll
call it X naught Y naught as the point
where you're inputting this has to be 0
and then similarly the partial
derivative with respect to the other
variable with respect to Y at that same
point has to be 0 and both of these have
to be true because let's just take a
look I don't know let's slide it over a
little bit here this tangent plane if
you look at the slope you imagine
walking in the Y direction you're not
increasing your value at all the slope
in the Y direction would actually be 0
so that would mean the partial
derivative with respect to Y would be 0
but with respect to X when you're moving
in the X direction here the slope is
clearly negative because as you take
positive steps in the X Direction the
height of your tangent plane is
decreasing which corresponds to if you
take tiny steps on your graph then the
height will decrease in a manner
proportional to the size of those tiny
steps so what this gives you here is
going to be a system of equations where
you're solving for the value of x naught
and y naught that satisfies both of
these equations and in future videos
I'll go through specific examples of
this for now I just want to give a good
conceptual understanding but one very
important thing to notice is that just
because this condition is satisfied
meaning your tangent plane is flat just
because that's satisfied doesn't
necessarily mean that you've found the
maximum that's just one requirement that
it has to satisfy but for one thing if
you found the tangent plane at other
little peaks like this guy here this guy
here or all of the little bumps that go
up those tangent planes would also be
flat and then those little bumps
actually have a name because this
because this comes up a lot they're
called they're called local minima or
local Maxima sorry so those guys are
called local Maxima Maxima is just the
plural of maximum and local means that
it's relative to a single point so it's
basically if you walk in any direction
when you're on that little peak you'll
go downhill so relative to the neighbors
of that little point it is a maximum but
relative to the entire function you know
these guys are the the shorter mountains
next to Mount Everest but there's also
another circumstance where you might
find a flat tangent plane and that's at
the minimum points right if you have the
global minimum the absolute smallest are
also just the local minima these
inverted Peaks
you'll also find flat tangent planes so
what that means first of all is that
when you're minimizing a function you
also have to look for this requirement
where all the partial derivatives are
zero but it mainly just means that your
job isn't done once you've done this you
have to do more tests to check whether
or not what you found is a local maximum
or a local minimum or a global maximum
and these requirements by the way often
you'll see them written in a more
succinct form where instead of saying
all the partial derivatives have to be 0
which is what you need to find they'll
write it in a different form where you
say that the gradient of
function f which of course is just the
vector that contains all those partial
derivatives its first component is the
partial derivative with respect to the
first variable its second component is
the partial derivative with respect to
the second variable and if there is more
variables you would keep going you'd say
that this whole thing has to equal the
zero vector the vector that has nothing
but zeros as its component and it's kind
of a common abuse of notation people
will just call that zero vector zero and
maybe they'll emphasize it by making it
bold because the number zero is not a
vector and often making things bold
emphasizes that you want to be referring
to a vector but this gives a very
succinct way of describing the
requirement you're just looking for
where the gradient of your function is
equal to the zero vector and that way
you can just write it on one line but in
practice every time that you're
expanding that out what that means is
you find all of the different partial
derivatives so this is really just a
matter of notational convenience and
using less space on a blackboard but
whenever you see this that the gradient
equals zero what you should be thinking
of is the idea that the tangent plane
the tangent plane is completely flat and
as I just said that's not enough because
you might also be finding local maxima
or minima points but in multivariable
calculus
there's also another possibility a place
where the tangent plane is flat but what
you're looking at is neither a local
maximum nor a local minimum and this is
the idea of a saddle point which is new
to multivariable calculus and that's
what I'll be talking about in the next
video so I will see you then